es una situación especialmente delicada
por las implicaciones que puede tener en
el proceso de paz de 1998 y el regreso
de la violencia como mencionas han sido
seis días de violencia de
enfrentamientos ininterrumpidos hasta el
momento 55 policías han resultado
heridos en estos enfrentamientos y un
número alto también de civiles la
jornada de hoy de anoche fue una de las
más violentas dado que los republicanos
e unionistas a los lealistas lanzaron
bombas molotov a la comunidad católica
republicana en lo que se conoce como los
muros de paz en belfast es tan grave la
situación que la asamblea regional de
irlanda del norte y su gobierno de
coalición del partido unionista de
irlanda y el sinn fein han sido
convocados de manera urgente para poder
encontrar una solución política a esta
delicada situación